former New York City Mayor Rudy Giuliani
is with us mr. mayor you've been telling
these people how to do their job it's
not like you don't have experience you
have had to deal with this pretty much
the whole time you are a mayor and you
did it successfully you would think they
would listen and can you please explain
why there now as a de Blasio and Cuomo
fight amongst themselves and they don't
ask for the National Guard that it is
their job to ask for that the president
that might have to invoke an 1807 law to
bypass them and insert the power because
they're not doing their job the de
Blasio Cuomo problem is a special
problem they hate each other and and
frankly de Blasio is completely
incompetent and the governor really in
good conscience should replace him
because he's the sole reason why the New
York City Police Department isn't acting
and it really wasn't fair the governor
who attacked the police department he
should have attacked de Blasio he knows
what I know
so I will tell you this Sean this is
absolutely true
de Blasio over the last three or four or
five nights calls individual police
chiefs and tells them not to enforce the
law he tells them not to make arrests he
goes around the police commissioner and
does that it's outrageous
mr. mayor I want to don't watch people
stealing and not interrupt them unless
somebody is holding them back the person
holding them back is mayor de Blasio I
know that Cuomo knows that everybody
Governor Cuomo has the authority he's
the governor of the state does he not
have the authorities of property we have
cops also man is done in Buffalo New
York too he has the authority to ask the
president Maggio is not just not
enforcing the law he is interfering in
the enforcement of the law and the
governor should remove them and this
city this should never happen in this
city we have a 35,000 person police
department I had 10 times where they
attempted to do this to me and they
never got beyond first base
I had to arrest 700 people once with
chief Esposito we did it
they've only arrested a measly 200
people last night and I rode up and down
Madison Avenue today and I went all the
way down the Union Square and my city
it's disgraceful the man should hang his
head in shame what he's allowed to
happen to the mayor the governor is a
disgrace of a mayor now for you
throughout the country are much better
this is happening in progressive liberal
democratic cities because they are very
friendly to criminals they let him out
of jail they let him out of jail on
ridiculous bail [ __ ] they let him out
of jail and the minute thieves
coronavirus they let them all out of
jail and they start raping people I did
you to New York man Marin there's a
Minneapolis let them take the police
precinct it said to an Tifa and all the
national groups let's come in and push
these cops around because their
political leaders will not support them
the cops are being victimized it's the
political leadership the left leadership
that is allowing this to happen in 30 or
40 immense demands and they were all
democratic mr. mayor the governor has
the authority to call in the guard
himself because it's also happening in
other parts of the state he hasn't and
this governor you seem to be giving him
a pass he's the one that signed the bill
that mandates that criminals have no
bail at all so they get instantly
released and sit go right back to where
they were in the middle of the Anarchy
because of his law why does it he call
nobody can do right now sitting there in
all video wherever he is he can remove
de Blasio and he could order the police
commissioner of New York to enforce the
law and this will end in 24 hours what
about those National Guard should they
ask the president the National Guard the
New York City Police Department is
bigger stronger better and knows what
it's doing more than the National Guard
the National Guard is trained to defend
us in war the New York City
each department has kept us out of riots
for twenty years twenty four years under
me and Bloomberg they just need a mayor
they just didn't make I've got a runner
said they shouldn't stops interfering
with them they're the best law
enforcement organization in the United
States and the people I agree twice as
big as the FBI they're twice as skilled
as the FBI I rely on them to do my mafia
I'll get all that one thing I think he
should call in the guard and number two
he needs to suspend immediately the
nobel law that he signed into action but
mr. mayor thank you for being with us